as the bombings continue so does the
misery
just over the last month according to
the UN close to 700 000 ukrainians have
been forced out of their homes
over the summer there were actually more
refugees re-entering the country than
leaving that's turned around again and
experts say likely to get worse people
who had been holding out with winter Now
setting in may have to give up if there
is widespread power outages and you know
Sub-Zero temperatures there's just not a
possibility for people to stay
the numbers are staggering inside
Ukraine an estimated 5.9 million people
are displaced the number forced out of
the country is even bigger more than 7.8
million fled to Europe Canada's
contribution 132
000 refugees were brought to this
country the reaction was quick and
bipartisan although uneven different
provinces have decided to do different
things so you know some of the Maritime
Provinces have been very proactive um
you know even chartering planes and
getting people to Canada other provinces
have been a little bit like well if they
come we'll deal with it in the first
weeks of the war there was a rush to get
out about 200 000 people were leaving
every day we were on the ground in
Poland and Western Ukraine most of the
people we met didn't know where they
were going only that they couldn't stay
This Girl's family said they were
waiting for a bus they didn't know the
destination they did know it was better
than being at home
she says she and her family spent five
nights hiding in their basement
now with that sense of urgency the
European Union dropped the regular
Asylum system and granted ukrainians
temporary protected status the candidate
was called temporary residence status it
gave displaced ukrainians immediately
Access to Health Care education and the
ability to work Refugee Advocates have
praised the reaction but also pointed
out how different it is from the way
refugees from the Middle East and Africa
have been treated in recent years it
stands out because it is in Stark relief
to the welcome or lack thereof for
people from other places and even
frankly for people who were in Ukraine
from other countries so
um African students or International
students from elsewhere who were
racialized who are studying in Ukraine
and when they went across the border
we're told no no this is for ukrainians
now there are challenges ahead for the
millions of ukrainians outside their
country conflict ends do they try to
stay where they've settled or try to go
home
if they choose to return then there's
the question of what are they going back
to
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal